for machine learning I think meta
programming
I think we could generally say is
extremely useful
and so you get features I mean I'll jump
around but there's the feature of Auto
tuning and adaptive compilation just
blows my mind well so okay so let's come
back to that all right so so what what
is what is what is machine learning like
what or what is a machine learning model
like you take a pie torch model off the
internet right
um it's really interesting to me because
what a pipe what pi torch and what
tensorflow and all these Frameworks are
kind of pushing compute into as they're
pushing into like this abstract
specification of a compute problem which
then gets mapped in a whole bunch of
different ways right so this is why it
became a meta programming problem you
want to be able to say cool I have I
have this neural net now run it with
batch size a thousand right do do a do a
mapping across batch or okay I want to
take this problem now running across a
thousand CPUs or gpus right and so like
this this problem of like just describe
the compute and then map it and do
things and transform it or like actually
it's very profound and that's one of the
things that makes machine Learning
Systems really special uh maybe can you
describe Auto tuning and how do you pull
off I mean I guess adaptive compilation
is what we're talking about is meta
programming yeah how do you pull off
auto-tune I mean is that is that as
profound as I think it is it seems like
a really like uh you know we'll
mentioned list comprehensions to me from
a quick glass of Mojo uh which by the
way I have to absolutely like dive in uh
as I realize how amazing this is I
absolutely must dive in uh it that looks
like just an incredible feature for
machine learning people yeah well so so
what is autotune so take a step back
Auto tuning is a feature in Mojo it's
not so very very little of what we're
doing is actually research like many of
these ideas have existed in other
systems and other places and so what
we're doing is we're pulling together
good ideas remixing them and making them
into hopefully a beautiful system right
and so Auto tuning the observation is
that it turns out hardware systems
algorithms are really complicated turns
out maybe you don't actually want to
know how the hardware works
right A lot of people don't right and so
there are lots of really smart Hardware
people I know a lot of them uh where
they know everything about okay the the
cache size is this and the number of
registers is that and if you use this
what length of vector it's going to be
super efficient because it Maps directly
onto what it can do and like all this
kind of stuff or the GPU has SMS and it
has a warp size of whatever right all
the stuff that goes into these things or
the dial size of a TPU is 128 like these
these factoids right
my belief is that most normal people and
I love Hardware people also I'm not
trying to find literally everybody in
the internet
um but uh most programmers actually
don't want to know this stuff right and
so if you come at it from perspective of
how do we allow people to build both
more abstracted but also more portable
code
because you know it could be that the
vector length changes or the cash size
changes it could be that the tile size
of your Matrix changes or the number you
know an a100 versus an h100 versus a
Volta versus whatever GPU have different
characteristics right a lot of the
algorithms you run are actually the same
but the parameters these magic numbers
you have to fill in end up being really
fiddly numbers that an expert has to go
figure out and so what Auto tuning does
it says okay well
guess what there's a lot of compute out
there
right so instead of having humans go
randomly try all the things or do a grid
search or go search some complicated
multi-dimensional space
how about we have computers do that
right and so Auto tuning does is you can
say hey here's my algorithm
if it's a a matrix operation or
something like that you can say okay I'm
going to carve it up into blocks I'm
going to do those blocks in parallel and
I want this this with 128 things that
I'm running on I want to cut it this way
or that way or whatever and you can say
hey go see which one's actually
empirically better on the system and
then the result of that you cash for
that system yep you save it and so come
back to twisting your compiler brain
right so not only does the compiler have
an interpreter that she used to do meta
programming that compiler that
interpreter that met a programming now
has to actually take your code and go
run it on a Target machine
see which one it likes the best and then
Stitch it in and then keep going right
so part of the compilation is machine
specific yeah well so I mean this is an
optional feature right so you don't have
to use it for everything but yeah if you
if you're so one one of one of the
things that we're in the quest of is
Ultimate performance yes right ultimate
performance is important for a couple of
reasons right so if you're an Enterprise
you're looking to save cost and compute
and things like this ultimate
performance translates to you know fewer
servers
like if you care about the environment
hey better performance leads to more
efficiency
I mean you could joke and say like you
know Python's bad for the environment
right and so if you move to Mojo it's
like at least 10x better just out of the
box and keep going right
um uh but but performance is also
interesting because it leads to better
products and and so in the space of
machine learning right if you reduce the
latency of a model
so that it runs faster so every time you
query the server running the model it
takes less time well then the product
team can go and make the model bigger
well that's actually makes it so you
have a better experience as a customer
and so a lot of people care about that
so for auto-tune for like towel size you
mentioned 128 for TPU you would specify
like a bunch of options to try yeah in
the code it's a simple statement and
then you can just set and forget and
know depending wherever it compiles
it'll actually be the fastest and yeah
exactly the beauty of this is that it
helps you in a whole bunch of different
ways right so if you're building so
often what will happen is that you know
you've written a bunch of software
yourself right you you wake up one day
you say I have an idea I'm gonna go put
up some code I get to work
I forget about it
I move on with life I come back six
months or a year or two years or three
years later you dust it off and you go
use it again in a new environment and
maybe your GPU is different maybe you're
running on a server instead of a laptop
maybe whatever right and so the problem
now is you say okay well I mean again
not everybody cares about performance
but if you do you say okay well I want
to take advantage of all these new
features I don't want to break the old
thing though
right and so the typical way of handling
this kind of stuff before is you know if
you're talking about sequence templates
are you talking about C with macros you
end up with if defs you get like all
these weird things get layered in make
the code super complicated and then how
do you test it right it becomes this
this crazy complexity multi-dimensional
space that you have to worry about
and you know that just doesn't scale
very well